de la difficulté là avec ses différents
projets de pipeline mais elle semble
finalement avoir trouvé une solution une
façon d'exporter du pétrole qui
proviennent des sables bitumineux de
l'Alberta donc en attendant que les
projets de pipeline puissent aller de
l'avant mais c'est par bateau que son
cœur va exporter son pétrole sur le
fleuve et ce sera à partir de Sorel le
Tracy de Martin Chabot
depuis des années les compagnies
pétrolières dont sont encore cherchent
par tous les moyens à exporter leur
production pétrolière venant des sables
bitumineux plusieurs projets de léoduc
même si certains sont approuvés sont
loin d'être prêts le lieu du gnoden
Gateway fait face à l'opposition des
communautés autochtones qui stands vers
le Texas est toujours en attente
d'approbation la ligne 9 dan bridge
s'arrêtera à Montréal car le projet
d’inversement de la ligne verso
Sportline a été suspendu et le projet
énergie s de TransCanada vers gros
kakouna et Saint-Jean du
Nouveau-Brunswick fait également face à
de l'opposition on sait que le secteur
pétrolier canadien est en et surtout
albertin est à la recherche de voies de
sortie pour la production Albertine donc
toutes les alternatives sont explorées
serait le tracé pourrait être une de ses
voies de sortie depuis une semaine
jusqu'à 60 wagons citerne provenant de
l'ouest du pays viennent ici pour
décharger jusqu'à 36000 barils de
pétrole par jour l'équivalent de 2
piscines olympiques mais quelle sorte de
pétrole et vers ou exactement on peut
imaginer que le pétrole qui est produit
en albertin et qui arriverait jusqu'à
Sorel serait mis par bateau pour aller
rejoindre le Texas
son corps refuse de préciser la nature
exacte du brut qui transigera par serrel
ni sa destination mais dans sa notice
annuel 2014 publié en février la
compagnie annonçait déjà ses intentions
de faire transiter du pétrole des sables
bitumineux par Sorel surpris les groupes
environnementalistes ont l'impression
que son corps passe par en arrière pour
faire ce qu'elle n'ose pas faire par la
porte avant ça passe par Montréal ça
passe par la rive sud Boucherville ça va
jusqu'à Sorel et la compagnie non secret
secret industriel nous on vous dit pas
ce que dans le train moi je trouve que
ça a aucun bon sens
à côté de septembre deux pétroliers
partiraient de Sorel chaque mois et
s'ajouterait aux dizaines d'autres qui
circulent déjà tous les mois par le
Saint-Laurent ici Denis Martin Chabot
Radio-Canada Montréal